is net zero less of a priority for the
government
but not at all i think that uh the net
zero
legislation it is after all uh in in law
uh is still the law of the land we're
focused on that but of course given
what's happening around the world given
the pressure on energy prices we're also
doing lots of other things to make sure
that we get independence energy
independence back uh into the uk
we want to have a security of supply we
want to live in a world where we're not
dependent on what russian policy is but
we have more control
over energy sources here in in britain
and that's what the strategy is all
about
yeah what people care more most about at
the moment though of course is the
impact that it's going to have on their
energy bills when will they see the
difference
you're absolutely right i mean in terms
of people's energy bills our people's
energy bills this year
uh we've
announced the measure of uh a number of
measures the 9.1 billion pound uh
package 150 pounds
of uh council tax for people in bands a
to d
uh 200 pounds uh to to pay those bills
and of course you're right to say that
the strategy
is more of a a medium-term three four
five year uh
answer
but that doesn't mean we can't address
this i think it's really important
that we get an energy
strategy and energy policy that means
that we can have more security and
independence
in the years ahead
how comfortable would you be living next
door to a wind farm
i've said that i don't personally have
uh issues with wind farms but of course
i've also very clearly said
that uh wind farm onshore wind farm
developments have to be made with local
consent that doesn't work without that
and that's what we're that's what we're
committed to in the strategy
okay um let's move on to the front page
of the daily mirror today in the news
this morning do you um let's have a
quick look at that do you agree
uh with the chancellor
rishi sunak who says that because his
wife isn't an elected politician
journalist shouldn't be asked questions
about her
look i agree with him that it's
completely unfair to be bringing someone
who is uh not a politician
and and and essentially attacking them
uh in the way that that's happening
um i i totally agree with him on that
how does it look to the british public
that while they're being asked to pay
more tax from yesterday
um the the wife of the man who is asking
us to do that
is earning millions from overseas
investments
and not paying a penny
so she's uh i
looked at her statement uh yesterday
she made it very clear
that as an indian national she can't
have dual citizenship
and she's got a non-dom status here in
the uk
now after 15 years staying she will be
domiciled but for the moment
she pays tax on
uk income as i understand and
uh on foreign income she pays the tax
outside the uk that's what non-domiciled
status means but i haven't come here to
comment on on on her tax affairs
we're talking about the british public
and the optics um if i may you are here
to represent the government today not
just on your own brief that's your job
this morning on behalf of her majesty's
government and i'm asking you about the
optics of the british public who are
being asked to pay more money and making
the choice between heating and eating
half a million kids in absolute poverty
and the woman who is married to the
bloke that is enforcing all of that on
us is not paying a penny in tax for
overseas earnings i'm asking you about
the optics of that for my viewers this
morning
so all i've said is your people can
reach obviously their own conclusions
and that's up to the viewers but all
i've said is that uh he's made full
declaration of uh what's happened uh
it's a non-domiciled status that is
utterly legal everything
is completely in order he's always been
very transparent
about about these issues
she set up a business uh with others
called dig me fitness it went under only
went under
after it had taken quite a lot of money
as part of the furlough scheme debts of
415 000 pounds uh that has been left uh
to the a british taxpayer uh to pick up
and again i would put it to you that
this is somebody who is richer than the
queen who is living in the very heart of
westminster representing your government
are you completely comfortable with that
i'm totally comfortable with people
having
businesses
people operating what they do as private
citizens i'm completely comfortable
about that and i think everything has
been uh
open and declared
and i'm happy with that i don't know the
details um obviously i'm not
an expert on on
those financial financial arrangements
but i think absolutely uh that people
have a right to
pursue their own business interests
635 000 pounds in follow payments for a
company that collapsed
look i don't know about i'm i don't know
about the details of the businesses that
were uh that you're referring to
um but i know that everything uh has
been uh fully declared um i know that uh
the chancellor has put this all in his
declaration of interests and i also am
aware that the non-domiciled status is
something that's been in british law for
230 years
can you accept at all that it might um
irk the british public
the people will draw their own
conclusions and that's what we that's
the great thing about this country we
have an open debate people will have
lots of different views i've just come
here to say
very clearly
that i think
her tax affairs are a matter for her
um and i don't know the details of the
businesses that you've referred to no i
understand that i understand that but i
i can't understand why you don't
appreciate that somebody can't feed
their kids put food in their bellies and
put the lights on in the house as well
and yet somebody else who's married to
somebody who's making us make those
decisions is making millions in overseas
earnings and not having to pay a penny
in tax
we've rehearsed this i said there's a
non-domiciled status that you uh clearly
and lots of people are aware of
um and everything's been declared that's
that's that's what i've said okay let me
ask you about okay let me ask you this
instead then do you agree with the prime
minister that biological males should
not be competing in uh female sporting
events
yes i do i think it was very clear it
was very refreshing
to see a
the leading politician in our country be
very clear about that i happen to agree
with him on this
okay um
the charity stone wall i'm sure you're
aware of them are saying that a blanket
ban would be fundamentally
unfair why are they wrong
i think that we've seen uh in america
and other places
people who are uh biological males you
know smash uh records
uh and win lots and lots of uh uh races
and i think that that's
uh i think that's unfair i think what
the prime minister said chimed with
millions of people's views up and down
the country uh that it's unfair to have
biological males uh competing uh with
biological uh females uh in in
things like swimming contests and
cycling
um you're completely comfortable with
what's happening at number 11 down in
the street what about number 10 uh are
you comfortable that the prime minister
um in the words of the leader of the
opposition presided over widespread
criminality while in office
so again you know we've been here uh
many times i think it's important that
the police uh go through the full a
metropolitan police go through the full
investigation
they're doing that
as i understand a number of people have
been issued with fines
uh and uh
that's up to those uh individuals
uh concerned we've had sue grey as well
looking at what's happened and i'm just
very interested in looking into the
conclusion uh of those reports yeah the
interim report says that 20 times the
law was broken in downing street that
some would say that's widespread
criminality i'm asking you to comment on
what might happen i'm asking you about
what the police have already told us and
are you completely comfortable with the
prime minister who's presided over the
law being broken 20 times already in
office
what i am comfortable with is with the
prime minister who's shown incredible
leadership
uh in this russia ukraine crisis that's
not what i'm asking you about minister
point it out
no you're asking me about whether i'm
comfortable with the prime minister and
i'm 100 no i'm not i didn't ask you that
i asked you whether you were comfortable
with him
presiding over law breaking is what i'm
asking you specifically
so on that specific point i'm saying
that let's see the full extent of the
inquiry but the underlying your question
was somehow some suspicion that the
prime minister no that was in the front
that's specifically what i was asking
about no there was no sidebar to it at
all okay let me put let me put this this
the justice secretary the justice
secretary says laws were broken at
downing straight do you agree with him
or do you think he's misspoken
look i was saying is that i think we
should look at the full extent of the
report i want to wait and see the full
gray report i want to wait and see the
full uh outcome
of the metropolitan investigations we're
in an interim stage as you said okay and
i think we should i won't i will make my
conclusions once uh this process is
completed okay so the jury is still out
for you
thank you
thank you
take a look at what i think i just said
let's wait let's wait and see
where this thing ends up thank you bye
thank you bye